After its notorious run in the 90s, Beavis
and Butt-Head returned to MTV in 2011, but
that ended up being a pretty big failure.
So what exactly happened?
Keep watching to find out why the Beavis and
Butt-Head revival failed.
In the 90s, Beavis and Butt-Head was more
than a little controversial.
It upset a lot of people thanks to its crude,
rude, destructive, and antisocial characters.
Beavis' love of playing with fire and its
supposed role in a real-life copycat act in
which a kid burned down his family home led
MTV to ban all references to fire in the series.
Even a legislator criticized the show on the
floor of the United States Senate.
That all just made Beavis and Butt-Head seem
super edgy.
If not for the series testing the public's
appetite for sick and twisted animation, there
might not have been shows like South Park
and Family Guy following in its wake.
“She said, 'Wood.'
That was cool."
"Yeah.
Wood!
Wood!"
"You're right!
Beavis and Butt-Head made room for a vast
TV landscape full of adult animation, so much
so that by the time it reappeared on MTV in
2011, it didn't feel that provocative anymore.
If anything, it felt like a cynical cash grab
to some viewers.
USA Today interviewed students at the University
of North Carolina at Asheville about the revival,
and many of them felt the show was just playing
into rampant '90s nostalgia.
As one one student put it,
"I think it's a poor way for [creator] Mike
Judge to try and capitalize on the memories
of kids who grew up in the 90s."
Not only was the whole vibe of Beavis and
Butt-Head possibly played out by 2011, but
so was the show's content.
It had struck a chord in the early 90s because,
despite being a crudely animated series, it
felt like a slice of real life.
The title characters were a couple of bored
teens who watch TV, hate school, and busy
themselves with troublemaking.
They seemed far more realistic than any other
portrayal of young adults on TV, like the
ones on Beverly Hills, 90210 or Saved By the
Bell.
But when Beavis and Butt-Head returned in
2011, their activities still felt like a slice
of '90s life, instead of 2010s life.
Try as they might, the new Beavis and Butt-Head
writers had a tough time updating the characters
for the modern world.
After all, they still wore the same T-shirts
bearing the names of AC/DC and Metallica,
two bands a little past their prime and no
longer favored by the average 15-year-old.
While the Beavis and Butt-Head revival felt
like a 90s time capsule, its creative staff
and the powers-that-be at MTV did try to update
a big chunk of the show's format.
When the series premiered in 1993, MTV aired
hours of music videos each day, and Beavis
and Butt-Head would scan through such outlets
to find videos they could either headbang
to or savagely mock.
But by 2011, MTV had moved away from videos
and towards reality shows about teens and
young adults.
And so, when Beavis and Butt-Head reemerged
that year, they would watch one or two music
videos per episode for old time's sake.
But they would mainly provide catty commentary
on MTV's library of reality shows, such as
Jersey Shore or 16 and Pregnant.
Unfortunately, this didn't really work out
as well as making fun of videos, and as a
result, Beavis and Butt-Head were strangers
in a strange land, lost souls from another
time.
Television is a business, and networks determine
what shows to renew and keep investing in
based on how many viewers they pull in, which
helps set advertising rates.
Generally speaking, the better a show's performance
in the Nielsen ratings, the more likely it
is to be profitable and earn another season.
With this in mind, the end of the Beavis and
Butt-Head revival may have come down to a
simple business decision about viewership
Nostalgia-driven viewers initially turned
out for the revival.
The premiere episode, broadcast on October
27, 2011, attracted 3.3 million viewers.
In the coveted 18-49 demographic, it pulled
a 1.8 rating, defeating all other shows on
cable primetime that night.
Still, Beavis and Butt-Head didn't bring in
as nearly as large of an audience as the show
it temporarily replaced in its time slot,
Jersey Shore.
Still, MTV had to have been happy with those
initial numbers.
But they definitely weren't pleased with the
ratings that subsequent episodes earned.
Viewers didn't stick around from week to week,
with the season finale on December 29, 2011
drawing a paltry 919,000 total viewers.
One major factor in MTV's decision to not
bring back the revived Beavis and Butt-Head
for a second season involved some good old
corporate interference, or rather, a lack
thereof.
While Mike Judge ended the series of his own
accord back in 1997 due to dwindling creative
energy, he felt recharged by the time the
reboot rolled around.
And he apparently had plenty of gas left in
the tank because he didn't actually want the
show to end when it did for the second time.
Sadly, the show never came back, in 2012 or
any year since.
As Judge told Mandatory in 2014,
"That kind of caught up in some kind of changeover
of the top brass of MTV."
Oftentimes, when new TV executives come in,
they want to focus on their own projects,
and not those of their predecessors.
And that very well could've been what doomed
the revamped Beavis and Butt-Head.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.